[Music]
foreign
here in this video we will talk about
the real-life Megalodon shark and its
rivals in the ancient Seas these
gigantic sharks were noted as apex
predators but the oceans of the world
are expansive and there are other Apex
species as well some of which rival in
size While others having numbers or even
intelligence to their advantage it's not
just a guess or a probability but a
definite inference that the giant sharks
were in constant battles against these
other species so we will dive into the
deep and discuss firstly the growth and
life cycle of the Megs along with
habitat and prey and then go on to the
comparison between it and the Rival
species and which one might have caused
the extinction of the Megalodon we will
also tell you how they might have either
hunted or killed each other in the past
so let's get to it
so the Megalodon sharks were an extinct
mackerel shark species that live around
23 to 3.6 million years ago estimates of
its size reached between 15 to 20.3
meters or 50 to 67 feet in length and
weighing around 50 to 100 metric tons it
wasn't the biggest sea creature or
Marine predator of all time but it is up
there in the top 5. the mechs likely
gave birth to life pups preferring warm
coastal areas as nurseries infant
megalodons were about 3.5 meters or 11
feet long which grew at a slow and
gradual pace and therefore also faced
predation from other predatory sea
creatures fossils of megalodons have
been found globally in various
environments with a broad temperature of
Tolerance due to mesothermia they lived
in shallow and deep Waters transitioning
between Coastal and oceanic habitats at
different life stages as for food items
or prey anything is good as long as it
isn't poisonous
so let's go to the timeline and what are
the competing predators that existed
around the same time as these monstrous
sharks so these mechs lift around 23 to
3.6 million years ago from the myocene
to the pliocene epochs so that in itself
shows a highly successful species
lifespan and also there must have been
quite a few Rivals over the long period
of time the ones that we do know are
three of them mainly predatory whales
the first is the Olivia turn Melville
which existed around 10 to 8.9 million
years ago just over a million years
sharing the Seas with the Megalodon the
second one is the sperm whale although
fossil records are poor there is still a
tentative conclusion that these true
sperm whales emerge around 5 million
years ago and therefore would have
shared the Seas with a mix for about 2
million years the third rival is the
killer whale this one right here is
known as The Wolf Of The Sea it evolved
into being around the same time as the
sperm whale it might be the smallest
here but it definitely was and still is
the deadliest of all the three
anyway let's compare the sizes first and
then go on into their interactions with
the Megs so the estimations of the
Megalodon sharp varied widely because
they were initially thought to have been
predecessors of the great white shark
but it is now suggested that they are in
fact mackerel sharks the mechs are
thought to have been anywhere between 15
to 20 meters or between 50 to 66 feet
long and weighing 50 to 100 tons the
livyatan melvale was also a beast it was
thought to have been of a similar size
between 13.5 to 17.5 meters or 44 to 57
feet in length and weighing around 50 to
60 tons the sperm whale is on average
around 16 meters or 52 feet long but
large males have been documented to
surpass even 20 meters or 66 feet longer
than the Meg and the record size is 24
meters or almost 80 feet long and that
right there is a behemoth of the Seas
with a weight easily more than 100 tons
so going to the third one the Killer
whales are the smallest year with a
record size of 9.8 meters or just 32
feet long and weighing around 10 tons
so starting let's go with the
interactions between the Megalodon and
the Leviton malvale these were ancient
behemoths they differ in size slightly
they differ in movements senses and
behavior as well the Leviton move around
5 to 20 miles per hour using tail motion
while the Megalodon swam slower at 11
miles per hour with body and tail
movements with short bursts of speed
that could reach around 20 miles an hour
Leviton stays and smell were limited but
had sonar or echolocation while the mag
excelled in vision and smell both relied
on size and speed for defense against
one another the leviton's teeth and bite
adapted to Ambush other prey items while
the Megalodon's colossal Jaws possess a
powerful bite force that could attack
anything directly these ancient Titans
navigated prehistoric oceans with unique
attributes and strategies so in a fight
the Leviton one-on-one with a similar
size Mech would lose most direct battles
but since it is an ambush predator and
can dive deeper and use sonar to detect
thread but it could surprise attack a
shark and take the win the Megalodon
which is still a shock and had to
constantly move in order to breathe is
at a disadvantage compared to the
Leviton who could die 500 meters down
and lay in a still position for a long
period of time waiting for the opportune
moment so the balance between these two
species could have gone either way
depending on different situations and
circumstances
next the interactions between a sperm
whale and a Megalodon so to start off
sperm whales are swifter than megalodons
and short bursts yet the Megalodon
constant speed could match the sperm
whale over long distances however the
sperm whale could dive into deeper
depths which would be a death zone for
the Meg the whale's defenses include a
larger size blubber protection and
living in a port of several large
individuals the Megalodon safety relied
on its size and heightened sensors akin
to a great white shark's abilities
detecting electrical charges chemicals
and motion the mech boasted a powerful
bite force as well and a very large jaw
while sperm whales wielded massive heads
for ramming storm tails for slapping and
disorienting clicks sperm whales also
flaunt some of the world's largest teeth
measuring 8 inches long that could do
great harm especially to smaller Max
specimens but the sperm whales have
evolved in a different direction they
have evolved to hunt smaller creatures
like a variety of species even other
smaller sharks and giant squids and
therefore would not go head to head
against a larger Megalodon individual it
would rather just dive and hide until
the shark goes away the win in the short
run goes to the Meg in an encounter but
the fact that the sperm whale still
exists today is evident of their most
successful survival strategies
now lastly their interactions with the
killer whales alright starting with the
size disadvantage with a stomach
capacity of nearly 10 000 liters
findings indicate that the Meg with its
huge jaw had the ability to consume prey
up to 8 meters long in one go this
implies that the killer whale could have
potentially been devoured whole by this
shark but that's the thing killer whales
are too smart to be captured unawares
except during mating times and they
travel in parts of 15 to 50 individuals
each with the same sonar abilities and
intellect able to move as a pack and
coordinate attacks efficiently they are
also twice faster than a Meg so they can
either outpace it or even outmaneuver it
in a fight one-on-one there is no
competition but unlike the movie the
mech-2 the mechs do not hunt in bags
they were solo predators and therefore
the numbers are on the side of the orcas
when killer whales confront Megs they
would employ a strategic approach their
cutting coordination would prove the
vital Factor so while one orca distracts
the shark another one inflicts small
bites initially these nibbles might not
harm the shot yet the cumulative effect
over hours will wear it down and Bleed
It Out especially biting off the max
tail piece by piece till it is
immobilized though a Megalodon bite
could easily eliminate an orca if there
was a minor mistake their coordinated
efforts ensure a constant attack and
replacement of tight individuals through
a patient and calculated campaign the
intelligent orcas will emerge Victorious
as seen in their tactics against larger
prey items like the blue and sperm
whales today in the present times yet
creatures weigh larger than the Meg are
prey items to these Wolves of the sea
and they on occasion even hunt and eat
great white sharks too meaning smaller
mix are a dinner Delight since their
habitats go inside everywhere this means
that there is a high probability that a
killer whales actually wiped out the
Megs from the planet either through
Bells which might happen more often than
not killing of the smaller Max specimens
of juveniles or more likely by competing
for the same prey items the larger
slower whales thus the killer whales
might have started off the Meg from its
food items and effectively wiping them
out of the planet
so isn't that surprising the killer
whales the smallest ones made the
biggest ones extinct anyway I hope you
have enjoyed watching this video do hit
that like button for support and
subscribe but most of all smash that
Bell icon for regular updates and new
videos right here on this channel till
the next one take care fam